تتواصلوا في نيويورك تفاعلات طلب رئيس
مالي لموافقه الدوليه على نشر قوه عسكريه
دوليه لمساعدتها في استعاده السيطره على
شمال البلاد
وتتزعم فرنسا جهد ضفد دوليا لحشد الدعم في
مجلس الامن لهذا التوجه لكنها تقول انها
لا تخطط لتدخل عسكري هناك وتعول على الامم
المتحده ودول غرب افريقيا
تتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
الرايسيين ما فرص الاستجابه الدوليه لطلب
رئيس مالي بقوه عسكريه دوليه للسعاده
السيطره على شمال البلاد
وما هي المحاددات التي تحكم اي قرار دولي
او اقليمي في هذه المواجهه
عبر التصريحات الصحفيه على الاقل يبدو
خيار تدخل العسكري في مالي ضد تنظيم
القاعده في بلاد المغرب الاسلامي
والجماعات المسلحه المتحالفه معه قد وجد
دعما وحراكا على جبهات عده
يصعب التكهن بتطورات الاحداث في جمهوريه
مالي اكبر دول غرب افريقيا والتي تعيش على
نذر صراع مسلح بتدخل دولي منذ انقلاب
الثاني والعشرين من اذار مارس الماضي الذي
اطاح برئيس البلاد المخضرم اما دبتوري
رئيس مال الانتقال ديوكوندا تراوري في
موقف لا يحسد عليه واستجد بالامم المتحده
ثلثاء اراضي بلاده في الشمال تسيطر عليها
مجموعات تتبع لتنظيم القاعده في بلاد
المغرب الاسلامي متحالفه مع حركه تحرير
ازواج وهي كيان الانفصالي قديم مؤلف من
الطوارق اوضاع شمال مال انعكست محليا
واقليميا ودوليا وفي الذهن اختطاف
الدبلوماسيين الجزائريين في ابريل الماضي
وتطورات ملف الراهين الفرنسيين بالنيجر
وتزايد الحديث عن عمل عسكري هناك تنفذ
قوات اقليميه تدعم لوجستيان من فرنسا
وغيرها بموافقه مجلس الامن الدولي
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
مع مالي يمهد الطريق امام قوات من
المجموعه للتمركز في العاصمه باماكو مما
يمثل اذا حدث براي مراقبين بدايه تدخل
عسكري بعنوان اعاده الشمال البلاد باحضان
الدوله
فرنسا اعلنت ان مجلس الامن قد يعقد قريبا
اجتماعا للدراسه طلب مال رسميا التدخل
الخارجي عسكريا في الشمال وهنا يطل موضوع
الرخائن وشكل تفاعل مجموعه الدول الحريصه
على سلامه رهائنها مع اي تطورات مستجده
واشنطن تحارب القاعده منذ سنوات في مختلف
الجهاد لكنها تمسك في مال العصا من
منتصفها واعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه
ضروره انتهاء احداث شمال مالي بتسويه
سياسيه متفاوض عليها رغم انها ادلت
بتصريحات سابقه فهم منها وجود رابط بين من
وصفتهم بالجماعات الارهابيه بشمال مالي
والهجوم الذي اودى بحياه السفير الامريكي
في ليبيا
يبدو خيار التدخل العسكري في مالي اذن
بانتظار موافقه مجلس الامن فقط ولكن ما لم
يحسم هو تفاصيل ذلك التدخل وكيفيه محافظته
على مصالح مؤيديه وهذه امور خارجه عن
السيطره بل قد يحرك بيادقها بشكل او باخر
اولئك المسيطرون على شمال المال ايا كانت
صفته
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من نواكشوط
محمد محمود ابو المعالي الكاتب الصحفي
المتخصص في شان المالي ومن باريس الدكتور
خطار ابو دياب الباحث في المعهد الدولي
للدراسات الجيوسيه محمود محمد محمود ابو
المعالي هل يبدو لك من خلال هذه التصريحات
حول
احتمال ان يكون هناك تدخل عسكري في الشمال
مالي ان اي عمليه ربما في هذا الاتجاه
باتت واقعا ينتظر ترتيبات معينه لكي يتحقق
طيب شكرا
انا اتصور ان اي تدخل في منطقه ازواد تحول
دونه عقبات كثيره واعتبارات عديده منها
اولا ان الدوله المركزيه في مالي وهي
المعنيه اولا بهذا التدخل وهي المطالبه به
ويتوقع ان تكون راس الحربه فيه هذه الدوله
شبه مفقوده حاليا وفي وضعيه انهشه للغايه
تتنازعها اهواء الاقواس الراغبه في تثبيت
اركان حكم
العسكريه بقياده وهي الحاكم الفعلي حاليا
في باماكو
ايضا قد يرغب في التدخل الدولي لكن
ومجموعه كاتي ترفض هذا التدخل ايضا الدول
المحيطه بازوات الجزائر وموريتانيا
ترفضاني هذا التدخل والنيجر ايضا التحقت
به اخيرا اذا هناك عوامل تحول دون هذا
التدخل نضيف الى ذلك ان الفرنسيين بكل
تاكيد وهم الغرب لن يكون لهم تدخل مباشر
لاعتبارات عديده منها تجربه التدخل
السابقه في افغانستان وفي غيرها منها ايضا
وجود رهائن غربيين بيد الجماعات المسلحه
في ازواج ايضا التدخل يعني اندلاع حرب
اهليه يعني تجديد كل الحركات الاسلاميه
والليبراليه والسكان وغيرهم لمواجهه اي
قوى تجد او قد تحاول التدخل في منطقه
ازواد نجد ان حركه تحرير ازوات وهي حركه
انفصاليه ليبراليه مناوبه للحركات
الاسلاميه لوحت بالتحالف مع الحركات
الاسلاميه في حال اي تدخل ايضا التركيبه
لاذنيه في ازواج فهو يتالف اساسا من طوارق
ومن عرب ومن سنغال سنغاي في
غالبهموكو لكن العرب هو الطوارق اغلبهم
يطالبون بالانفصال وي اي تدخل من قوات
الاكواس وهي قوات افريقيه سيلقي حساسيات
اصلا الموجوده بين هذه المجموعه العرقيه
اي انه سيكون لصالح الاثنيه
الافريقيه على حساب الاثريه يعني المعقد
الموضوع معقد ومتشابك وتتداخل فيه في
السياسه والمظالم التاريخيه
وغير ذلك هنا اريد ان اسال الدكتور خطار
ابو دياب يعني اذا كانت فرنسا وهي ادرى
الدول الغربيه بحقائق تاريخيه وجغرافيه في
المنطقه وسياسيه وامنيه ايضا لما لا تقول
هذا الجهد الدوري الان وتطالب بتدخل عسكري
في المنطقه وهي التي لا تريد اصلا ان يكون
لها دور اساسي في هذه العمليه
هذه المساله تعود لمارس من هذا العام
عندما جرت انقلاب فيماكو وبعد ذلك
استغلت جماعات الطوارئ مع الجماعات
المتشدده الاخرى هذه الفرصه واستفادت من
الاوضاع المستجده في ليبيا المجاوره لكي
تستولي على شمال مالي
صديقنا من موريتانيا يتكلم عن منطقه ازواج
بالطبع هي منطقه تاريخيه للطوارق لكن هناك
مناطق تاريخيه للطوارق في النيجر والجزائر
وغيرها وحتى في ليبيا الاهم ان مع الوقت
حركه الطوارق التي اعلنت حكم الذاتيا هناك
ودوله تبين انها لا تسيطر على الارض بل ان
جماعات انصار الدين من جهه وجماعه التوحيد
والجهاد والقاعده في المغرب الاسلامي الى
جانب عصابات التهريب من كل حد صوب كل
هؤلاء يحكمون السيطره على شمال مالي اصبحت
الصوره الان بالنسبه لفرنسا على الشكل
الاتي شمال مالي ممكن ان يتحول الى
افغانستان او الصومال يمكن ان يكون هناك
طالبان جديده عندما نرى ماذا فعل هؤلاء مع
اجمل مراكز التراث الاسلامي البديع في
تباماكو وغيرها نفهم جيدا خطوره هؤلاء على
المدى الطويل ليس فقط على مالي بل على
الجوار وفي هذه المنطقه هناك نفط وغاز
وهناك يورانيوم في النيجر اذا نعم هناك
تعقيدات اثنيه وغير ذلك نعم هناك ضعف في
باماكو لكن هناك مخاطر متصله بتصدير
الارهاب الى ابعد من هذه الدول ومن هنا
هذا الجهد الفرنسي هو من اجل ان تتحمل دول
غرب افريقيا مسؤوليتها كما تحملتها سابقا
في الازعاج بليز مستعدة مع دول اخرى
لتقديم دعم لوجيسي واستخباري دون ان تكون
لها القياده على الارض سنرى اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده المتردده حتى الان ستلعب
اللعبه وسنرى ايضا اذا كانت روسيا والصين
اللتان تعطلان الحل في سوريا ستعطلان ايضا
الفرصه في مالي وربما قد يفسر هذا النظره
نظره الريبه والشك وايضا مخاوف دول الجوار
لامالي في وايضا حتى الدول الاقليميه
نستطيع هنا ايضا الراي الجزائري الجزائر
التي رفضت
يعني ان يتدخل المجتمع الدولي عسكريا في
المنطقه نسمع من العاصمه الجزائريه دكتور
احمد عظيمي او ساده العلوم السياسيه
والاعلام بجامعه الجزائر يعني لماذا هذه
المخاوف الجزائريه ما الذي تخشى منه
الجزائر
عمليا اذا ما اعلن او انطلقت اي عمليه
عسكريه في شمال مالي
لا هو معروف معروف جدا وهنا التجارب كثيره
الان في العالم معروف ان اي تدخل اجنبي لا
يحل اي ازمه بل يؤذنها اكثر التجربه
موجوده في العراق موجوده في افغانستان
موجوده في جهات كثيره لم يحدث ابدا ان
جيوش اجنبيه استطعت حل مشكله داخليه وهذا
موقف الجزائر الجزائر تقول ان على المجتمع
الدولي ان يساعد الماليين الماليه ان تكون
هناك سلطه مركزيه قويه ولها امكانيات انه
دعم الجيش المالي بالامكانيات وبالمعلومات
وبالتدريب وبالوسائل التقنيه وام لا نت
عسكرين يحل المشكله على اساس حوار بين
الماليين انفسهم ان يقوم الماليين انفسهم
بمحاربه الارهاب وليس بتدخل اجنبي التدخل
الاجنبي وخاصه اذا كان هناك تدخل من طرف
اوروبيين
هذا سيجعل كل ارهابيين العالم وكل من يريد
ان يحارب يسمونهم بسلاميين وكل من يريد ان
يواجه الغرب كلهم سياتون الى مالي
وستعتحول المنطقه الى افغانستان اخرى
وافغان اخرى ستؤدي الى وجود
رحمه دكتور احمد يعني هناك من فسر الموقف
الجزائري على انه في الواقع هو خشيه ان
يكون اييه او تكون لاي عمليه عسكريه هناك
ارتدادات على الداخل الجزائري بحيث ربما
اي استهداف لتلك الجماعات المسلحه وتنظيم
القاعده في بلاد المغرب الاسلامي في شمال
المالي قد يؤدي الى عوده هؤلاء الذين
تخلصت منهم والجزائر على الاقل
اكيد انه لما يكون هناك تدخل اجنبي على
حدود اي بلد البلد الاخر يتعرض ايضا
لاخطار هذا التدخل الاجنبي ما يقع اليوم
في افغانستان يؤثر كثيرا على باكستان وعلى
حدود الدول الاخرى لدينا 1300 كلم مع مالي
وبالتالي اي تدخل اجنبي في سيؤثر هذا اكيد
على حدود الجزائر لكن المشكل ليس هنا
الجزائر لديها امكانيات هذه الشيء اقوى
جيش في المنطقه وتستطيع ان تواجه الارهاب
وواجهته بمفردها وبدون اي تدخل اجنبي
والارهاب من مكان في الجزائر كان اقوى
بكثير مما هو موجود ومع ذلك استطاع
الجزيره المشكل ليس هنا المشكله هو هل
يريد المجتمع الدولي هل فعلا المشكله في
المال وفي الساعه ويريد ان يقضي فعلا على
الارهاب في هذه المنطقه ام انه يريد ان
يجيب الذريعه للتدخل
جامعه الجزائر بناء على ما قلت سنبحث في
الجزء الثاني
ان كانت هذه القراءه ربما او هذه الاسباب
ستؤدي الى تدخل بشكل ماء بحيث يخضع هذه
المنطقه للنفود الدولي سنبحث ايضا كيف
سنعكس هذا المزاج الاقليمي متردد على
الحراك الدولي بشان يناقض اليك بعد فاصل
قصير تنتظرون مشاهدينا الكرام بعد هذا
الفاصل
اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي تتناول
تفاعلات طلب رئيس مال موافقه دوليه على
نشر قوه عسكريه دوليه لمساعدتها في
استعاده السيطره على شمال شمال البلاد
دكتور خطر ابو دياب اذا كانت فرنسا
تعلم ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او
الصين او روسيا او قوه اخرى لن تساعدها في
تحقيق هدفها لتدخل عسكريا واذا كانت
امريكا غير
متحمسه كما يبدو واذا كانت دول الجوار
والدول الاقليميه خاصه دول الاكواس يبدو
انها متحفظه ولها مخاوف من تداعيات اي
تدخل دوري على المنطقه لماذا
تقود فرنسا هذه الجهود
وهذا قد يؤدي ايضا الى بس سيطره
يعني سيطره منافسيها على منطقه تابعت لها
تاريخيا من حيث النفود
نعم تاريخيا هذه المنطقه كانت تسمى المربع
الافرانكوفوني لكن شتان بين زمان كانت فيه
فرنسا تلعب دور الجدارما
الشرطي في هذه المنطقه من العالم وهذه
الايام فرنسا قامت بتعديل سياساتها حتى
السياسه الحاليه مع الرئيس هولندا ووزير
الخارجيه فابيوس بالنسبه لموضوع مالي تبدو
اكثر نشاطا مما كانت عليه في اخر ايام
سركوزى وهذا يبرز امكانيه للقطيعه او
للتباين بين عهدين من ناحيه اخرى الولايات
المتحده
ليست المساله في الحماس او عدم الحماس
المساله في التقييم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تعتبر ان الدول الافريقيه
المجاوره ليست مؤهله لوحدها لمحاربه هذه
الجماعات القويه في شمال مالي وهي ربما
تستانس براي الجزائر الجزائر التي تعتبر
ان حدودها لا تزال في وضع صعب مع المغرب
وان وضعها بعد التحول في ليبيا اصبح اصعب
الجزائر تخشى المزيد من التحولات في هذه
المنطقه من العالم تنظر بريبه اذا الى اي
تحرك لا ينسق معها بشكل مباشر ومن هنا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تسعى اولا
للانتهاء من افغانستان ولكنها ايضا تركز
على اهميه منطقه الساحل لترابط ذلك مع
شمال افريقيا وربما ما يغضب ايضا الجزائر
ان الرئيس المالي اقترح مجيء قوات من
المغرب
بينما نرى محور اخر من الجزائر وموريتانيا
يشكل مع النيجر ما يسمى دول الميدان نحن
اذا امام انقسامات اقليميه ونوع من
الدوليه لا ادري اذا كانت روسيا والصين
ستذهبان بعيدا ام في الاحرى ستريثان
باتجاه انتاج حل اقليمي يرضى عنه الجميع
هذا ما يفتش عنه ليس هناك تدخل اجنبي هناك
سعي لحلق اقليمي شبيه مما حصل في ساحل
العاج في سيراليون وفي اماكن اخرى وبالفعل
نجحت دول غرب افريقيا حتى الان حيث لم
تنجح منظمات اقليميه اخرى محمد محمود ابو
المعالي اذا مصالح الاطراف المعنيه باي
تدخل في شمال مالي متضاربه هناك تحالفات
تبدو هشه كما ذكر الدكتور خطاب ابو دياب
يعني هناك مخاطر تحفه اي عمليه عسكريه في
شمال يماني وهذا ما نبه اليه الامن العام
للامم المتحده بانجيمون
برايك اذا ما يعني اقدم المجتمع الدولي
على خطوه محفوفه المخاطر كهذه ما الذي
يمكن ان ينتج عنها
طيب بدايه ضيفكم من باريس اصور فقط تحدث
عن ان زواج منطقه طوارقيه وان هناك
امتدادات في دول الجوار ازوات منطقه غير
خالصه لاثنيه معينه بل لا توجد فيها اثنيه
ذات اغلبيه هناك ثلاثيه اثنيات او اكثر
هناك طوارق هناك العرب هناك فضلا على
قليتها قليات من الفلان والممبار هذا فقط
للتوضيحي
نعم ردا على سؤالكم انا اتصور ان اي تدخل
اولا تدخل حسب تصوري لا يزال بعيدا منال
فالاكواس وحدها هي التي هي المتحمسه ولا
تملك مقدرات التدخل للمقدرات الميدانيه
ولا العسكريه والمنفذ الوحيد الذي يمكن ان
تتدخله منه حاليا هو باماكو عن طريق
الجنوب قادمه من باماكو وهناك ما اسرفنا
في سابق الحديث هناك مجموعه
مجموعه الانقلابيه ترفض هذا التدخل ويوم
امس تظاهر المئات ضد هذا التدخل في باماكو
موريتانيا والجزائر
محور رفض لهذا التدخل حتى الان لكل منها
مبررات وهذه لكل منها مخاوفها فهي على
الاقل دول الميدان دول المجاوره ستدفع
الثمن الاغلاق في حال اي تدخل الحل
السياسي المطروح هو الذي قد يلجا اليه في
النهايه المنظومه الدوليه لاعتبارات عديده
ولا تجريب الحرب الاهليه ثانيا تجريب
افغنت المنطقه ثالثا قد يدفع الاطراف
باسرها الى تقديم تنازلات واصوات فيه
اطراف عديده مذاهبها اهدافها مشاربها شتى
مختلفه هناك انفصاليون هناك الاسلاميون لا
يريدون الانفصال لكن لهم اهدافهم هناك
عامل مهم جدا دكتور محمد محمود ابو
المعالي هناك عام جدا في مهم جدا بالنسبه
لمن
يعرف تركيبه الاثنيه والترابط بالقبائل
وغير ذلك في المنطقه بالنسبه لمزاج الشعبي
في المنطقه هل سيقبل بوجود قوات على في
على ارض الشمالي مالي بما يمثل ذلك من
مخاطر على من هم يعني تجمعهم قرابات كثيره
اطلاقا اي تدخل اجنبي سيعني هبه شعبيه
سيعني التحاما بين الحركات الانفصاليه
والحركات الاسلاميه
والشعب والسكان المنطقه برمتها هناك
حساسيه مفرطه اتجاه هذه القضيه هذه
الحساسيه تغذيها اعتبارات منها اجنبيه
القوات القادمه وحساسيه ذلك منها الطبيعه
العرقيه لهذه القوات على حساب تركيب
الاثمانيه لسكان المنطقه منها ايضا ما
يتوقع ان تخلفه هذه الحرب وهذه المعارك
فكما يقال حين تتصارع الفيله تدفع الاعشاب
الثمن حين يقع تقع مواجهه بين الجماعه
وقوات الاكواس معناه ان الشعب هو ما سيدفع
معناه ان الدماء ستسيل معناه ان حربا
اهليه ستندلع تجد انه في تسعينيات القرن
الماضي حين كانت وحدها مالي تقاتل ضد
الانفصاليين ارتكبت فضائح من ميليشيات
باسم الجونديكاي محسوبه على النظام المالي
اليوم ستسرع المنشات وسترتكب المجموعه
الارقيه الفضائع فيما بينها لكل ميليشياته
لكل مسلحه لكل سلاحه
وايضا اي محاوله للاستعاده لن تكون دائمه
ولن تكون الا جزئيه في حاله
العواقب محمد
دكتور خطر ابو دياب بالتاكيد هذه الحسابات
لن تغيب عن عن يعني مفكره الدول الكبرى
هناك اجتماع يعني مرتقب في مجلس الامن
الدولي كما دعت اليه فرنسا لدراسه الوضع
بحث الوضع في مالي هل تتوقع ان يصدر عنه
اي شيء ام انه سيكرس انقسام في مجلس الامن
الدولي وهل سينتج عن هذا الانقسام ربما
خطوه منفرده من فرنسا في شمال مالي
سيكون هناك اما نقاش حاده في مجلس الامن
وتوصل لنتيجه ما في حدود منتصف اكتوبر اظن
اذا قدمت مجموعه دول الغرب افريقيا مع
مالي ورقه متكامله حول الاهداف والمهام
سيدعم مجلس الامن الدولي في نهايه المطاف
خطه من هذا النوع اي ستكون فقط اقليميه
بغطاء دولي لكن في حال قرر الدول الغرب
افريقيا لوحدها من دون غطاء من مجلس الامن
القيام بعمل ما لدعم الاستقرار في مالي
ستكون فرنسا الى جانب هذه الدول لماذا
لانه في حسابات الربح والخساره وفي حسابات
المخاطر ترك الوضع يستفحل في شمال مالي
منطقه للتهريب لخطف الرهائن للتشدد منطقه
تهدد امن ليس فقط الساحل بل شمال افريقيا
واوروبا اظن ان الجميع في نهايه المطاف لم
يسمح بذلك شكرا لك يا دكتور خطار ابو دياب
الباحثه في المعهد الدولي لدراسات الجيول
السياسيه واشكر من نواكشوط محمد محمود ابو
المعاني الكاتبه الصحفيه المتخصص في شان
المالي شكرا لكم مشاهدين الكرام والى لقاء
اخر في حلقه اخرى من برنامج الخبر